One of our goals as other is to launch a pensionary form
where we give pension pensioners 7,500 per month
and the reason for that well there's many reasons for it
but one of the main reasons is that
pensioners do not spend their money in foreign investments
they do not spend their money in in England
they do not spend their money putting money to Australia
so a pensioner that ends 2000
and doesn't take his money and go
give it to something in Australia or England
the fact that pensioners spend their money actual fact in a community
pensioners are very patriotic towards the communities
they're very uh
sopranistic towards the communities pensioners are very community pro
so the easiest way and the best way to invest in our car
in our economy is not to give it to loose cannons
but to give it actual to people that have an experience of life
that knows use the money for the benefit of the family
for the community for the health
so a pension No. 1 the house is paid up
No. 2
a pension doesn't have all the expenses as young people have No. 3
a pension is gonna spend their money on the homes on the clothing um
they gonna No. 4 they gonna spend their money on medicine
pensions are gonna spend money on uh
the needs of the home on school fees
so in other words the paints and money will be used
the Paints will use their money to secrete in the economy.
nobody thought about this because people refuse to think about this.
They steal hundreds of billions,
but they can't do this in the right area.
And what will happen is that the economy will be stimulated.
The economy will turn into faster pace.
The economy will move faster
because we're looking at 3.2 million pensioners that will actually
fake be using that money to build the environment,
the community, the home.
And this will cause a big overlap and in our economy
and our economy will increase.